hey what's up people of the wwe's i hope
everybody's doing well
loving life and being kind to each other
today we're going to talk about politics
going to work and friendship i've been
getting a lot of emails that ask
john ramseysolutions.com about going
back to work
and having trouble with uh politics
you're too conservative you're too
liberal you can't talk about the
president you can't be for the president
you can't be against them
oh black lives matter you're this all of
it has turned into this big mess
so i want to give some practical tips on
how i handle some of these conversations
both in my personal life and in my
professional life
for those of you who don't know and are
new to the john delony tubes show
i work with dave ramsey one of the most
prolific
radio voices in the united states i've
been co-hosting the dave ramsey show now
for the last several months
and i currently am employed by ramsey
solutions his parent company
so this email talks about a dynamic
between me and dave that a listener has
observed on the radio here we go dr d
what's up
what's up you and dave seem to be
totally different in many ways and
approaches to people and problems
how do you and dave ramsey overcome the
generational
cultural educational and ideological
differences you have
what have you learned from him what
skills have you developed since joining
the ramsay team
i'm curious as an avid listener
especially since you referenced brene
brown
someone whose work on shame i totally
respect but she is also someone who is
politically and ideologically totally
different from dave and even myself
thoughts thanks i love
this question it's so good everyone
every single person watching this video
is dealing with this right now
you've got parents who have different
political ideas than you do you've got
bosses who are ideologically different
than you you've got friends who suddenly
over the last six months
have come out of the woodwork and you've
seen a side of them that you really love
or you
really hate all of your friends on the
interwebs on the
on the cellular devices man they are
getting
loud and angry and fervent and canceling
and adding and subtracting all it's just
gotten bananas
and so i want to first say i
wholeheartedly
with all of my guts reject
the politicalization and the
polarization
of basic human interaction i reject it
out of hand
it's ridiculous my life doesn't work
that way
your life doesn't work that way and when
i'm talking to somebody who i care about
or i'm talking to a stranger at a bus
stop
and i mention hey i really like this you
can't then take me
and dump me into a bucket that tells me
everything else about my life
that's ridiculous it doesn't even make
sense but we do that to one another
we allow our political teams to do that
to our country
and it's just nonsense so i completely
out of hand reject
the politicalization and the
polarization of
every single topic the world is a slide
rule things are messier than that
at every place i've ever worked i've
been
too conservative over here way too
liberal over here
whoa way too conservative over here what
kind of liberal lunatic are you here
that's been my whole life and for
whatever reason i kind of like it that
way
i like people not knowing right where i
land on things
because sometimes i change my mind and
sometimes i have really strong beliefs
about something
then i get some more information i spend
some time with some people
i walk a mile in somebody else's shoes
and my beliefs about something transform
and that's happened all across the
political
and ideological spectrum over the last
20 or 30 years and that brings me to
this important
important point if you look back over
the last 20 years of your life
and you haven't grown up yet if there
aren't things in your past that you wish
i wish i hadn't said that or i thought
this but
now i've grown up and or i've been
enlightened or educated or taught
differently or had new friends and
now i think this if you haven't grown
god help you man and if you have grown
that's called wisdom that's called
growth that's called the cornerstone of
humanity
all of us should be growing developing
and moving towards
becoming better people that's the
journey right
so specifically for this question dave
ramsey and john deloney are just
different people
we have different life experiences we
had different parents we had different
friends
i went to a lot of school dave got a
bachelor's degree
dave's running a multi-million dollar
business for 30 years i've been working
in non-profit education world
i've got one dog i don't know how many
dogs dave has he has three kids i've got
two
all i have to say is we're different
people
our value systems are very much aligned
we both have a strong sense of family
and community
and we both get up every day of our
lives with
one unique singular mission and that is
to help
empower people and help empower
communities to take control of their
lives back
to be free from those things that are
holding them down
to get their voice back to stand up tall
and to
walk with their head held high along the
streets of their neighborhood
that's what we do we share those values
but there's a difference between values
and beliefs
i like to think of beliefs as just a set
of information
it's just a insert of information i
believe in this
i believe in that i've heard scientists
say
i believe in climate change and i've
heard people read an internet article
and say
i don't believe in climate change they
are just choosing to not believe in a
set of facts or to believe in a set of
facts that's what a belief is
i believe in god i don't believe in god
i believe my dog is the best dog ever
i believe your dog sucks right it's
beliefs are just
a set of information and sometimes dave
and i have different beliefs
here's an example of a belief a caller
calls on the radio
dave believes that the right way to
address this caller's pain
is to get loud my belief on how to
address that caller's pain is to get
quiet
our value system is exactly the same we
both want what's best for that person
but we have different beliefs on how to
go about getting that done and here's
the thing
what i know about dave ramsey is that if
i really felt strongly
in my heart that his belief was wrong
and in a respectful dignified way
i said hey dave here's the research
here's my experience
here's why i get quiet in this moment
and here's where getting loud may hurt
somebody
dave would take that into consideration
because he values
insight and care on the other side
dave may look at me and say john your
quietness your silence is part of the
problem
in this moment this isn't a moment for
oh how does that make you feel
this moment is to slam on the table in a
moment of injustice and say no more john
you got to get loud and i would hear
that because one of my values is
i want to love people the best way i
know how and sometimes i need a new tool
in my tool kit to help me love better
and in that case maybe it's volume right
maybe it's action
maybe it's response maybe it's quiet
maybe it's
think before speaking john maybe it's
fill in the blank
so there's a difference between beliefs
and values
so one of the great lessons i've learned
from dave ramsey since i've joined his
team
is that he is a ceo of a multi-million
dollar company
and he's a radio host so what makes him
unique for most ceos in the country
is that every day he spends three hours
with the front line customer
imagine how different the dining
experience would be at burger king
if every day for three hours if the ceo
of burger king took orders
and filled the lunch sacks the business
would be different
right so dave listens to the pain
and the hurts and the successes of three
hours worth of callers
every single day and that informs how he
runs his company
one thing dave is always pushing this
company to remember that
all of the energy all of the work all of
the lights the cameras all the stuff
is for one thing to honor and take care
of the person who's hurting and needs
our help
that's it never forget we're talking to
real people
with real lives not theories not
academic exercises not
what ifs real people real lives
desperate for some support in a crazy
crazy world and dave reminds me of that
all the time and i've really grown from
that
as for what skills i've picked up since
i joined the ramsay team
i didn't have instagram before i got
here no facebook
i've never sent a tweet i certainly
never been on the youtubes before
i didn't even know youtube channels were
a thing i've learned that
i've learned how to collaborate learn to
let people speak into my wardrobe
choices let people speak into my
speeches on stage
i've learned to take feedback on a radio
show i've never done radio before so
honestly it's more of what have i not
learned right i'm learning every single
day and at the end of this great email
the author mentions
me talking about brene brown how bernay
brown has some great things on shame
some good science but maybe some
different political and ideological
thoughts than dave or as the author
and i'll leave dave out of this because
i've never sat down and walked through
with him some of
brene brown's thoughts and i've never
sat down with bernay brown we're from
the same hometown
and we have quasi the same field i never
sat down and talked to her though
she's much more accomplished she's a
great author a great writer a great
researcher
and from what i'm told she's a great mom
a great friend
and a great partner with her husband too
but here's the thing
if i step back at 30 000 feet i think
brene brown's a lot more like dave
than people might think if i put down
the politics
if i put down the polarization both dave
and brene
really love people they're both people
of
deep and devout faith they both really
really want to help
individuals and systems groups of people
be free from the things that hold them
back whether it's best experiences
bad money habits poor decision making
trauma and the like so i would suggest
that dave and brene
probably share a lot of the same values
the same drivers that get them up every
morning now that manifests itself in
different beliefs
but i don't know i've never sat down and
talked to them i do know this
i love them both one i love up close one
i love from afar
and i share values with both of them and
i share beliefs that are different than
both of them
and i think that's whole and healthy and
good so to address the last part of this
question
about whether brene brown and dave
and you me we have different political
ideologies so maybe some good science
some things that we agree with some
things that we don't agree with
i mentioned brene brown a few times on
dave's show
i love her scholarship i love her work
we're from the same hometown in houston
there i've never run across her but i i
do respect her research i've heard she's
a great
fun wonderful mother friend
wife all those things right and i know
the same about dave
that he's a great husband his kids love
him his community loves him
and when i distill those two figures
down
into people of faith people who
truly get up every morning with one goal
that's to help other people live their
lives
more fully and more whole
people who are really fighting against
systems
right dave has decided to make his
life's work taking on
the financial system that cripples and
shackles people
and bernays take on systems of shame
systems that hold people down
spiritually and psychologically
their values appear to me on the outside
to be very similar
that manifests itself in different
beliefs different ways of going about
solving problems
but i tend to look at people for what
they are offering to the world
i tend to look at people for the things
they have in common not the things that
divide them
i'm tired of living in a world that is
either
or i'm tired of walking out and wanting
to hang out with my neighbor
and saying oh you're voting for them i
was thinking about voting
for them and now we can't have barbecue
together
this has gotten nuts it's gotten nuts to
the point that
i see somebody you may be following in
the imaginary world on the instagrams
and i'm just gonna assume everything
about what you believe
lock stock and barrel how you treat your
husband or your wife or your kids
what you do you kick your dog i just i
just superimpose my values my beliefs my
understanding
of you based on these little trinkets of
information
some of you have written in and you go
to work and you're bullied for your
beliefs you're bullied for not liking
the president you're bullied for liking
the president you're bullied for your
faith you're bullied for the way you
look stop
just stop i've sat with
thousands of people over the last 20
years and i
promise you we have more in common than
we don't and so to go full circle
are me and dave generationally
culturally educationally and
ideologically different
on some things he's old i'm still young
and handsome
i've got all my hair he doesn't have his
he's got
millions and millions of dollars in the
bank i've got more like dozens
but we both share a same set of core
values
that if each one of us was to get in a
room and really drill
down on we'd all be very similar i
promise you
as bernay brown says if you go looking
for places in the world where you don't
belong you will surely
find them let's let this video be the
moment
where we start looking for places where
we belong
where people are joyful where they are
optimistic where they are giving us hard
truths that we need to hear
let's start looking for ways we can love
one another
instead of looking for one more reason
why somebody is different than us
and while we're better let's start that
today
this is john delany with ramsay network
subscribe forward send this to your
grandma and your grandparents and to
your pets whoever you want to
i love you i'll talk to you soon take
care